[Musik]
und sämtliche eu-mädel laboratoren der
lavigna del Signore
wir waren Papst am 19 April 2005 wurde
aus Kardinal Josef Ratzinger Papst
Benedikt der 16 zum ersten Mal seit
einem halben Jahrtausend gab es wieder
ein deutsches Kirchenoberhaupt
wir waren Papst auch auf mich treffen
diese drei Worte ein kleines bisschen zu
für Bild durfte ich die letzten drei
Jahre des Pontifikats von Benedikt
begleiten vor allem aber treffen diese
drei Worte auf seinen engsten
Weggefährten zu seinen Privatsekretär
Erzbischof Georg Gänswein der vom ersten
bis zum letzten Tag an seiner Seite
stand umso mehr haben wir uns über seine
Bereitschaft gefreut noch einmal mit
Bild über unseren großen Landsmann auf
dem Stuhl Petri zu sprechen über Licht
und Schatten seines Pontifikats über
seinen ersten Tag im Amt und seinen
letzten
das war das erste Mal dass ihr dann
gesehen habe also unter dem großen
Gemälde Michelangelos der eben des
Jüngsten Gerichts saß auf einem Stuhl
der neue Papst und die Kardinäle ich
habe das von hinten sehr schön gesehen
die sind dann der Reihe nach nach vorne
gegangen also schön im Gänsemarsch
hintereinander um den neuen Papst
Ehrfurcht und Gehorsam Referenz ja jetzt
obedienza zu versprechen und als ich da
das erste Mal in seine Augen blickte und
es war eigentlich alles weiß also vom
vom neuen peleolus weiße Haare die Farbe
im Gesicht war weiß und der talaver auch
weiß ist meine große Freude aber es war
gleichzeitig eine große Erschütterung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
welche persönlichen Worte hat sein
Privatsekretär an den neu gewählten
Papst gerichtet ich habe nur gesagt
heiliger Vater ich gratuliere ich werde
sie ich werde all das mit meinen Kräften
tun was sie für Sie tun kann invita
it in Worte also im Leben und im Tod und
er hat er nur mit dem Kopf genickt und
hat Danke gesagt und dann war es auch
schon vorbei zusammen mit viel
italienischen weinschwestern und den
beiden privatsekretären bildet es sich
unmittelbar nach seinem Amtsantritt die
päpstliche Familie wie kann man sich
deren Alltag vorstellen Papst Benedikt
die Firma ist so heißen sie dann Papst
dann der über die beiden Sekretäre und
die Schwester wegen das war mehr oder
weniger wie eine ja wie eine Familie die
sich auch in dieser Form verstanden hat
und dieses familiäre Leben ist auch
etwas was für Papst Ben wichtig ist weil
er einfach auch eine atmosphärische
Hilfe braucht in der sich wohlfühlt also
die Jahre des Pontifikats waren keine
einfachen Jahre was sehr viel Schönes
dabei aber es waren auch sehr viele
Erfahrungen die wirklich
Kraft gekostet haben
Schmerz schmerzvoll waren und das Leid
und die Freude haben natürlich auch das
menschliche immer noch viel stärker
genährt und so sind wir mehr und mehr
auch zusammengewachsen man sah sie ja
von morgens bis abends ne bei der
heiligen Messe bei den Mahlzeiten bei
der Besprechung bei den Audienzen das
heißt die Zeit die gemeinsam verbracht
wurde war enorm und das über Jahre
hinweg es ist ganz klar dass natürlich
dann nach und nach eine Vertrautheit
eine persönliche Beziehung wächst die
vorher auf diese Weise nicht vorhanden
war wer sich mit der Biografie von Josef
Ratzinger befasst erkennt schnell dass
der Papst seit jeher ein Familienmensch
war sie wissen dass Josef Ratzinger der
jüngste von drei Kindern ist die älteste
war eine Schwester Maria und der zweite
Bruder der Ältere Georg haben ja fast
das ganze Leben beginnend mit dem
Seminar dem kleinen Seminar in
Traunstein San Michael über dann die
Studienzeit in Freising und München
dann später jeder auf seine Weise in
seinem Bereich miteinander verliebt da
ist zwischen ihm und seinem Bruder und
seine Schwester eine sehr ähnliches
Verhältnis entstanden und das nach dem
Tod seiner Schwester im Jahr einen 90
dann also sich ganz auf dem Bruder
konzentriert hat
jeder Mensch auch als Papst nimmt in das
Papstamt hinein ja auch seine
Vergangenheit mit er bleibt Mensch der
er war er bleibt die Person die er war
natürlich in der neuen Herausforderung
und mit den neuen Anforderungen seines
Amtes aber er hat sich in keiner Weise
irgendwie verbogen oder in irgendeiner
Weise gemeinsam müssen sie jetzt
irgendwie was anderes machen sondern hat
aber so seine natürliche Kontinuität
fortgesetzt wer Benedikt 16 persönlich
kennenlernen durfte und konnte der weiß
sehr gut dass das Außenbild das
gezeichnet worden ist oder sehr häufige
gezeichnet worden ist mit der konkreten
Person in vielen Punkten nicht identisch
ist er ist ein demütiger Mensch ein sehr
einfacher Mensch
ein sehr höflicher Mensch ein Mann der
also den Humor mag und auch mit Ironie
umgehen kann dass Josef Ratzinger ein
Mann ist der eher diskret zurückhaltend
manchmal auch schüchtern wirkte das ist
einfach eine Tatsache die es nicht zu
verleugnen gibt es ist auch kein
Nachteil die großen Eigenschaften die
Papst Benedikt bekommen hat die
Intellektuellen aber auch die geistigen
die anderen geistigen Fähigkeiten die
hatte entwickelt und er hat nie ein Hehl
daraus gemacht dass seine Persönlichkeit
eher auf Zurückhaltung ja manchmal auch
auf Schüchternheit ausgelegt ist das
Lebensziel für Josef Ratzinger war
tatsächlich Professorin zu sein das
heißt Lehrer zu sein das war vielleicht
die größte Gabe die die liebe Gott ihm
geschenkt hat er konnte etwas erklären
er konnte darstellen er konnte sprechen
unser deutscher Papst war auch ein
Bestsellerautor sein erfolgreichstes
Buch Jesus von Nazareth fand weltweit
Millionen Leser ein Auszug die segnenten
Hände Christi sind wie ein Dach das uns
schützt aber sie sind zugleich eine
Gebärde der Öffnung die die Welt
aufreißt damit der Himmel in sie
hereindringe in ihr Gegenwart werden
kann im Glauben wissen wir dass Jesus
seine Hände segnend über uns
ausgebreitet hält dies ist der bleibende
Grund christlicher Freude
die erste Auslandsreise führte Benedikt
den 16 ausgerechnet in die deutsche
Heimat über Nacht war der schüchterne
Professor eine Art Popstar geworden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für mich unvergesslich sind die Bilder
mit dem Schiff vom Rhein herkommend oder
auf dem Rhein fahrend links und rechts
dann die großen großen Massen der
Jugendlichen und diese große Freude die
also wirklich ansteckend war insofern
ist die erste Erfahrung Weltjugendtag
Köln eine Erfahrung die unvergesslich
bleibt und auch eine große innere Freude
verursacht hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe ganz am Anfang auch schon
gesagt dass zu den Grundeigenschaften
seiner Persönlichkeit gehört nicht nur
der Sinn für Humor sondern auch der
ausgeprägte Sinne für Humor bis hin auch
zu ihren und in vielen Begegnungen in
vielen Formen habe ich also erlebt wie
diese Humor immer wieder aufblitzte das
kann man auch in vielen anderen
Zusammenhängen sehen in denen er mit
Menschen zusammen war dass er
tatsächlich ein humorvoller Mensch war
aber ein sehr sensibel humorvoll und
sehr ein sehr feinfühlig humorvoller
Mensch er wollte mit Humor oder auch mit
Ironie in keiner Weise jemandem treffen
oder gar in irgendeine Ecke stellen oder
ihn von sich halten Humor ist ja
letztlich auch ein Kind des Glaubens das
ist also der Blick
auf den Petersplatz
ein Stock höher ist eben dann das
Arbeitszimmer des Papstes
und das ist das Fenster von dem aus er
jeden Sonntag den Angelus betet und
unten die Menschen dann mitbeten oder
warten
[Musik]
der größte und längste Schatten der auf
das Pontifikat von Benedikt XVI war der
des missbrauchs-skandals
war das Ausmaß der Verbrechen an Kindern
dem Papst von Anfang an bewusst damals
als der Kreuzweg gebetet wurde im
Kolosseum hat Johannes Paul II den
damaligen kardinalprojekt 13 gebeten den
Text zu schreiben und da kommt ihr eine
Station vor wo er eben tatsächlich
deutlich sagt dass es in der Kirche viel
Schmutz und viel Dreck gibt es heißt
viel Sünde das war sozusagen das erste
Mal dass nach außen sehr deutlich und
sehr eindeutig gesprochen wurde auch und
gerade im Hinblick auf das was
Missbrauch bedeutet
dann kam das pontifikal von Benedikt um
16 Uhr das heißt es ging weiter mit der
Aufklärung und vor allem es wurden dann
auch die es kam zu Begegnungen mit
Missbrauchsopfern sie haben alte
angedeutet USA in Deutschland auch
andere Länder in denen der Papst
missbrauchsuppe getroffen hat das hat
natürlich der ganzen Frage auch digitale
zusätzlich eine emotionale eine
persönliche Seite
aufgeprägt und die Überzeugung die der
damalige Kardinal perfekt und der Papst
Benedikt hatte wurde in dieser Form auch
bestätigt und bestärkt und die Linie
wurde eindeutig weitergezogen dann
später auch von Papst franziskus die
Vertuschung war eine große Versuchung
und genau dieser Versuchung hat er
wieder standen auch gegen Widerspruch
natürlich alle die daran Betreibern
haben gelernt man lernt aus Fehlern man
lernt aus Vergangenheit und können Sie
den zahlreichen
Opfern die es ja auch in Deutschland
gibt und die möglicherweise auch über
viele Jahre mit den Folgen zu kämpfen
hatten auch heute versprechen dass die
Linie weitergeführt wird und dass die
Kirche die katholische Kirche darf auf
einem guten Kurs geblieben ist es kann
ich nicht nur versprechen das kann ich
auch bestätigen
wie hat Erzbischof genswein als sein
engster Vertrauter die dramatischen Tage
des Rücktritts erlebt am Tag der
ankündigungsredets hat Papst Benedikt ja
eindeutig gesagt warum er diesen Schritt
für richtig hält und für ihn für
notwendig weil zwei Gründe genannt ist
eben die Kräfte die geistigen und
physischen Kräfte geringer werden das
andere ist das wird oft
unterschlagen seit ich tue diesen
Schritt ich mache diesen Schritt aus
Liebe zu Christus und aus Liebe zur
Kirche und diesen Schritt zu tun das
fordert natürlich also ein so gewaltiges
Maß an Demut
aber eine nicht weniger
geringen Anteil oder ein nicht
geringeres Maß auch an Mut
dass ich damals so nicht richtig
einschätzen konnte sondern erst gelernt
habe im Laufe der Zeit nach dem
Rücktritt ja ich saß zur Rechten des
Papstes der Papst das also das ist der
große Schwester Papst dann waren nicht
nur ein Stuhl sondern waren zwei Stühle
links und rechts weil auch da machen der
zeremoniemeister dabei war und ein
Zeremonie her und äh am Ende des
Konsistoriums hat eben der Papst hier
waren die Kardinäle versammelt
mitgeteilt was eben dann wie ein laufe
um die Welt ging das er vom Amt des
Papstes zurücktreten wird es war so dass
der Kardinal der kann also der hat das
Wort ergriffen und hat in einer
bewegenden Rede den Papst gedankt und
eben auch dafür dass dieser Schritt in
dieser Form mitgeteilt worden ist aber
auch ausgedrückt dass es also wie ein
Blitzer Seite im Himmel kommt
und das hatte noch gemerkt das war etwas
was er hat sozusagen sich zum Sprecher
derer gemacht die ist eine Kollegen im
Kardinalskollegium waren und man merkte
dass das wirklich
einschlug und eingeschlagen hat eine
Entscheidung in dieser Form darf nur
dann gefällt werden wenn er überzeugt
ist dass tatsächlich also für das für
die Kirche und für Christus das Richtige
ist im Rückblick ist es so dass ich nur
höchsten Respekt vor dieser Entscheidung
sollen kann und ich muss gestehen auch
wenn es mir schwer gefallen ist und
manchmal auch immer noch schwer fällt
dass sie das anzunehmen habe weil es
seine Entscheidung war seine ureigene
Entscheidung und diese Entscheidung hat
der mit Gott sozusagen mit Gott
ausgemacht und damit ist es endgültig
alle wussten im Haus also das ist das
letzte Mal dass wir das machen das
letzte Mal dass das letzte Mal sein
letztes Mal in allem
und es wird kein wiederkommen geben in
der Tat wurde dann vereinbart dass
nachmittags dann das Auto unten im
gotthilde sandama so wartet
wir sind da mit dem Aufzug wie so viele
viele Male runtergefahren unten warten
einige Kardinäle und eine für uns
überraschend eine große große Zahl von
Mitarbeitern im Vatikan die Benedikt
begrüßt haben das sind dann mit dem Auto
den Weg den wir jetzt gehen
bis hierhin bis zum
Hubschrauberlandeplatz Gefahren
Hubschrauber wartete schon auch hier
waren nicht wenige Leute nicht sehen
noch dieses Haus da war dein großes
Plakat Grazie Papa Benedetto wenn ich es
ist unvergesslich ja wartete also der
Hubschrauber
ja es wurden nicht sehr viele Worte
gewechselt sondern es wurde einfach
einmal Auto raus in den Hubschrauber
hinein Türe wieder zugemacht dann wurde
der Hubschrauber gestartet dann sind wir
hoch und man kann ja das direkt
praktisch hat sich hochgeschraubt und
dann ging es dann Richtung Norden und
dann Richtung Osten das heißt also
konkret um die Kuppel herum und dann
durch das alte antike Rom über praktisch
über all das was man an Rom schätzt
Richtung Osten das heißt Richtung vor
der Dunkelheit natürlich angekommen dann
eine ganz kurze Ansprache auf dem Balkon
nicht zum Innenhof sondern raus auf den
äußern auf die Piazza äh die also sehr
sehr voll war und da hatte er ja
in wenigen Worten sozusagen also auch
die Situation den Nagel auf dem Kopf
getroffen und sagt eben also nicht mehr
Papst sei in Kürze und dass jetzt den
letzten Weg oder das letzte Wegstück als
einfacher Pilger dieser Erde geht
sondern sämtliche
national Graz
seines Abendessen Wissen darum dass um 8
Uhr mit dem Schließen des großen portone
in Kassel Gandolfo das Ponte di gar zu
Ende geht also wir haben sehr deutlich
eben gehört wie wenn es Tor zu macht es
gibt also einen gesunden ein dumpfen
Knall den hatten wir während der Zeit in
der Welt draußen waren natürlich
regelmäßig auch gesehen und gehört
[Musik]
aber dieses Mal war es besonders und
damit Schluss
und dann haben wir nachher die
Nachrichten angeschaut ja die also die
italienischen Nachrichten teltionale und
wie immer in der Regel hat er dann
nachher seinen Bruder angerufen und dann
ist er die Kapelle hat sich
zurückgezogen komplett gebetet und
dann war das Pontifikat zu Ende
in Kastel ganz neu vor der päpstlichen
sommerresidents kam es wenige Wochen
später zur ersten Begegnung zweier
Päpste als Benedikt mit seinem
Nachfolger franziskus zusammen traf dann
23 März kam Papst Franziskus und Papst
Benedikt zu besuchen es sind natürlich
im Rückblick immer
Erfahrungen die
eine besondere Bedeutung haben weil es
eine erstmalige Erfahrung war
die beiden kannten sich auch nicht sehr
gut meine es war so dass der damalige
ärztliche von Buenos Aires da und dort
natürlich auch hier in Rom war und als
Kardinal auch Papst Benedikt besucht hat
mit den anderen Bischöfen von
Argentinien aber es war Neuland und mit
Neuland muss man halt so umgehen dass
man damit fertig wird auch als
imitierter Papst begann benedikt der 16
jeden Tag mit einer Morgenmesse in
seinem altersruhe sitzt in den
vatikanischen Gärten
daran teilnehmen zu dürfen war für
Außenstehende eine seltene und ganz
besondere Ehre wir beginnen die heilige
Messe um 7.30 und zwar ist da eben das
Heilige Vater Benedikt dann bin ich
dabei und hier haben wir die memories
diese italienischen Frauen und ab und zu
in der Vergangenheit öfters jetzt etwas
weniger sind immer auch
Gläubige da die die heilige Messe mit
uns mitfeiern das Wappen von Papst
Benedikt das war ein Geschenk der selbst
die Familie also von uns zu seinen 90
geburtstag
das ist also die Sakristei und hier wenn
ich jetzt den Schrank auf mache dann
sehen Sie verschiedene paramete in
verschiedenen Farben für die
verschiedenen Anlässe also rote mehr
darauf feste grün ist jetzt der Sonntag
oder weiß dann Mutter Gottes feste oder
hochfeste
lange vor seinem Tod hat der emeritierte
Papst Benedikt der 16 den Rückzug aus
der Öffentlichkeit angetreten nur noch
zu kirchlichen Großereignissen verließ
er seinen altersruhe sitzt im Juni 2020
kurz vor dem Tod seines älteren Bruders
Georg reißt er noch einmal in seine
Geliebte bayerische Heimat um Abschied
zu nehmen man sei dem 93-jährigen die
Freude dieses Wiedersehens an dass er
als Geschenk des Himmels empfunden hat
die Zahl der persönlichen Begegnungen
wurden von Jahr zu Jahr kleiner dabei
wurde seine Stimme immer brüchiger immer
leise eine Stimme die Zeit Lebens nichts
anderes wollte als 1,3 Milliarden
Katholiken den Weg zu Gott ein wenig zu
Ebenen
eine Stimme die vielen und die mir heute
fehlt nun kann jemand sagen darf man
sich eigentlich so freuen wenn die Welt
zu voller Leid ist wenn es so viel
dunkel ist und Böses gibt es ist ein
erlaubt so übermütig und fröhlich zu
sein und der andere kann er lauten ja
denn mit dem Nein zur Freude dienen wir
niemand machen wir die Welt nur dunkler
und wer sich selbst nicht mag kann auch
dem anderen nichts geben und ihm nicht
helfen kann ich dein Bote des Friedens
sein wir wissen es aus dem Glauben und
wir sehen es jeden Tag die Welt ist
schön und Gott ist gut und dadurch dass
er als Mensch unter uns hereingetreten
ist mit uns leidet und liebt wüsste
endgültig und handgreiflich ja Gott ist
gut und ist gut ein Mensch zu sein wir
leben aus dieser Freude und aus dieser
Freude heraus versuchen wir auch anderen
Freude zu bringen den Bösen zu werden
und Diener des Friedens und der
Versöhnung zu sein